hey what is up guys mkbhd here and this
is the nokia lumia 1020 and i've been
sharing a lot of the photos i've been
taking on this guy for a while with you
guys on social media so facebook and
twitter and instagram and stuff like
that but i've mentioned that the camera
on the back which is a 41 megapixel
sensor with carl's ice glass and a xenon
flash and everything is the only reason
that i have this camera or phone on my
radar at all in fact if this didn't have
the amazing camera that it does i might
not have even ever bought it it would
just be another uh windows phone 8
device and honestly that's not my thing
but i really love the camera on the sky
and taking pictures with it so that got
me thinking and i actually posted a
tweet about how slapping this camera on
the back of like any phone would
instantly make it better because it's
that good of a camera and then i tweeted
this
and a lot of you guys who are already
following me on twitter took that and
ran with it and it spurred a lot of
interesting conversation and a bunch
more suggestions so you guys came up
with a lot of interesting other dream
phone ideas so that was the inspiration
for today's video and just for this
quick video i'm gonna be talking about
what i've reconstructed and reconsidered
in my head this for me in 2013 is the
perfect impossible but perfect
smartphone
alright so the body and the outside
design of the smartphone would come
straight from the htc one there are a
lot of really nice design phones out
there already some people would probably
prefer sony design a lot of people would
want the iphone i would say the htc one
is the best designed phone out there and
i would go straight from that i'd
probably expand it a little bit there's
been some rumors of a bigger htc one max
coming out soon i'll have the links to
everything i talk about in the
description below that like button by
the way but essentially it would be a
big unibody smooth design it would have
the front-facing boom sound speakers and
it would be in mad black now as you can
probably tell i am personally not one of
those people who has to have a removable
battery as long as the battery is good
but i do kind of like external storage
so if i had to modify the one a little
bit i would have external storage added
maybe an sd card slot on the side but
more importantly that ultrapixel camera
it's just not cutting it for a super
high end phone as a dream phone so i
would replace it with none other than
the nokia lumia 1020s incredible camera
on the back obviously it's a 41
megapixel sensor like we said before has
carl's ice glass in there very fast
glass and of course that xenon flash
will it make the phone bigger a little
bit thicker yeah naturally but i think
it would definitely be worth it in terms
of the picture quality improvement you
get out of putting such an incredible
camera in such a small body for the
display i'd actually take it directly
from the oppo find 5. the find 5 has
been one of the most underrated devices
in a while and i've talked about it in
previous videos but the display on that
guy is magnificent it's a 5-inch 1080p
display it's an ips display of course
but more importantly it's very bright it
has really good color reproduction
excellent viewing angles excellent
outdoor visibility and of course it's
really sharp because it's a 5-inch 1920
by 1080 panel and it actually gets
really really dim so if you want to read
it at night you can turn the brightness
down a lot lower than you would think
relative to other ips displays so it's a
really really good display uh very high
pixel density and i would just smack
that right on the front of the dream
phone now underneath the hood naturally
it would be the highest end processor
available the most amount of ram
realistically available right now in
2013 that looks to be the snapdragon 800
cpu uh that looks to be about two
gigabytes of ram maybe three
again i made a video about the galaxy
note 3 about how that is supposed to be
the next huge flagship phone where it
basically has all the highest end specs
so let's get a better look at that in
about a month or two when samsung
unveils that but basically it'll have
the highest end internals possible and
no doubt that'll give it some awesome
performance no matter what you put on
paper now lastly i would have motorola
do the battery and this is because
motorola just knows batteries motorola
does battery technology better than
anyone else in the smartphone market
these days we've seen the droid razer
max which easily has the best battery
life of any smartphone out there 48
hours of usable life that's a little bit
insane and it's not even that thick of a
phone so clearly they know what they're
doing they made the moto x which is not
even a very big phone has a 2200
milliamp hour battery but with all the
little tricks they have up their sleeve
they were able to make that phone last
longer than the galaxy s4 and htc one so
if i had to pick one person to take care
of all the battery technology and use
all the tricks up their sleeve it would
definitely be motorola and i think in a
phone that's big enough to house the htc
one max and the big lumia 1020 camera
you can fit a big 3 000 milliamp hour
plus battery and of course with
motorola's optimizations that could just
get an absurdly long battery life now
the price is yeah it's a weird thing to
say because this isn't a real phone at
this point this is sort of the
frankenstein phone now but if i were to
say in terms of pricing and the way it's
sold i would want this to be sort of the
same way that google play edition phones
or nexuses are now so nexus price but
that's not very realistic but i would
want it to be sold with you know just
pure stock android 4.3 jelly bean
no carrier bloatware anything involved
then it would be sold off contract maybe
in the google play store and it would
arrive in two days if i ordered it from
the play store uh and that would be the
way it would be priced sort of like a
nexus maybe we call it the google play
edition
one
lumia max or something ridiculous like
that now of course there are going to be
many different versions of this perfect
smartphone i mean some people are going
to have different ideas of what
perfection is to them at a phone some
people will want an lg display some
people will want a samsung display some
people will want the iphone's design or
maybe they want windows phone os in it
that's why i'm asking you guys this is
basically a video to get your thoughts
on what your perfect smartphone would be
so if you have a perfect sort of combo
of frankenstein phone leave that in the
comment section below the like button
and if you see someone who has posted
one that you like give that comment a
thumbs up so everyone can see the most
popular franken phone some people
actually would want a small variation to
an existing phone like a nexus 4 with a
1080p display or the lumia 1020 with
android on it you know just little
changes to existing devices other people
are gonna have equally crazy things like
i just talked about in this video that
are obviously impossible but are still
fun to look at and of course after all
that has been said we still have a bunch
of awesome devices to look forward to
this upcoming year we have you know the
oppo find seven we have now the lg g2
that i'll be taking a look at i will be
reviewing the lumia 1020 very shortly we
also have you know the new iphone coming
out soon we have the galaxy note 3. i
made a video all about why i think the
galaxy note 3 is going to be one of the
most important devices to look forward
to for the second half of 2013 but no
matter how you look at it the next
couple of months of phone and tablet and
device releases are going to be insane
so i'll leave my galaxy note 3 hype
video down below it'll be the first link
below the like button so you can check
that out but either way this has been a
quick fun video looking forward to
seeing your comments and talking with
you guys below thank you for watching
and i'll talk to you guys in the next
video
peace
so
you